salut
cette année il ya eu un peu moins de
casse tête que les autres années mais là
on va se reprendre là à se reprendre
surtout parce qu on a chopé des
casse-tête de qualité des petites rareté
des trucs un peu exceptionnelle à
trouver dans celui que nous faisons
aujourd'hui qui s'appelle la logbox et
qui a été remportée aux enchères par mes
potes de l'insoluble vous savez c'est la
société de castel dont je vous parle de
temps en temps je vous mets un lien vers
eux dans la description en plus d'avoir
des bons casse-tête et des bons conseils
quand ils repèrent très très cool
maintenant ils le disent qu'est-ce que
la logbox considérée comme une boîte
casse tête de difficulté bien bien relou
elle a été design et par erik feller qui
a dit je cite c'est mon meilleur design
de casse tête que j'ai fait de la vie
bravo eric 133 copies seulement ont été
réalisés de cette boîte tout à la main
dans du bois précieux et seulement 87
d'entre elles sont en circulation à
l'avant et j'ai deux petites
informations quand même du type no
gravity move n'ose pas ni une ôta pineau
banging or forces in necessary d'accord
soyons comme ça bref merci à hubert de
l'insoluble de me l'avoir envoyé fin
juin met un chronomètre ça fait cinq ans
que vous le dites quand est-ce que tu
mets des chronos pour qu'on voie je
mette un chronomètre mais je n'arrêterai
si je fais des pauses alors on commence
par l'exploration donc a priori c'est
une boîte qu'il faut ouvrir on a cette
clé là qu'un petit trou là et k4 on
appelle ça déjà [ __ ] ça commence bien
quatre morceaux en fait pour faire en
deuxième ben normal ce serait pour
appuyer sur les pistons est-ce que ça ça
bouge non
à ça ça bouge
ça fait un truc avec le trou pas ok à
l'intérieur quand je joue vrai comme ça
il ya ça il ya un trou en prusse encore
une vidéo à titre ici quatre pistons de
cap tailles différentes ici c'est un peu
incroyable j'imagine que vous êtes en
train de voir un plan mais on est en
train de voir des étages genre un trou
un étage un trou un étage un tronc un
étage un trou un étage encore un trou en
dessous avec une grande rigueur centrale
qui va me permettre de faire descendre
sa dedans et je pense qu'il va falloir
trouver en fait d'un chemin un petit peu
comme un labyrinthe quelque chose comme
ça oui j'ai vu mon doigt je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai fait ça j'ai là j'ai mis
mon doigt dedans on a clairement quelque
chose qu'ils bougent dans cette partie
là écoutez
rien avoir de ce côté de la là non plus
là on a un petit trou là dedans comme un
convoi on voit bien ce petit trou est-ce
que ça ça bouge
ça sa bougeotte sa bougeotte la salers
de plus bouger d'ailleurs à non à 6 il a
aussi sa bougeotte et là il n'y a pas de
trou laissé le soin comme ça puis c'est
bien voir là je peux le pousser vers le
haut qu'est-ce que ça dans l'autre sens
je ne pense pas ou alors c'est bloqué il
ya encore un autre trou ici alors là ce
trou à l'air plus profond que ce trou là
bon ben voilà on a fait le tour faut y
aller quand faut y aller faut y aller
allez on remet ça à l'intérieur on est
parti là je l'enfoncer à fond pour voir
je tourne à gauche ça fait rien et je
peux pas tourner à droite je ne peux pas
remonter d'accord donc je vais essayer
de faire les étages peut-être plus un
parent étages du dessus je peux pas
tourner non plus
non plus là non plus sortir ou parfois
[Musique]
pas grand chose à faire avec ça là on a
des petits trous est-ce que ça on peut
essayer d'enfoncer dans un des petits
trous c'est pas con
non pas tellement et ses autres trucs la
côte est est ce qu'on peut appuyer su
élever un peu comme en faisant un petit
levier non
aux attentes
edit dont elle aurait pas grandie macler
l'a1
passerelle serait pas plus grande plutôt
leur site
cette clé est contente de moi
apparemment de black bouffe ah oui
d'accord c'est carrément un aimant qui
sort ok ça c'est pas mal ça me permet
peut-être de voir s'il ya des zones
aimanté ou aimant table là dessus la ici
c'est mental ça peut aller dans le trot
dont classé mans tableur va savoir
maintenant si haut et un truc à bouger
quand j'ai fait ça vous attendez
donc clairement une pièce qui bouge
on va chercher s'il ya deux trois
endroits aimant table
voilà beh web alors de ce côté là il ya
un endroit qui est bien bien aimant
table
ccc là où il ya clairement un
autre aimant puisque vu comment ça
retient ces deux aimants haut et je peux
appuyer comme un bouton à c'est trop
bien stylé merad et ça fait un petit
bouton on a sur lequel on peut appuyer
comme ça
donc je me passe et voir si on pouvait
les shops etc
ah
oui d'accord donc là on peut tout
prendre lui il a pas la même polarité
que là n'est pas du tout
donc lui a l'air fixes et donc je
pouvais enlever les
3a et là ça me permet de faire un tour
complet dans l'autre sens ce n'est
peut-être pas du tout possible avant
dernière j'y vais à fond d'un débuté
pour voir s'il n'y a pas un mécanisme
mais maintenant que j'essaie 3ème en
tête je peux en mettre un dans ce trou 1
dans ce trou
là ça fait rien ah si j'appuie dans lui
en vrai je peux même pas vraiment
appuyer quoi j'ai toujours cette pièce
qui bouge là deux côtés et lui peut-être
je peux le mettre dans ce trou
si j'ouvre çà çà çà me peux me permettre
si j'en mets un là de faire la clé plus
profonde du coup ci est-ce que c'est
intéressant pour puisse y aller plus
loin ou pas pas du tout on aussi aux
d'accord donc là là je les pulls enfoncé
à fond alors que la clé était ouverte je
vous fais voir là j'ai agrandi la clé et
du coup lâché en butée sauf que
maintenant en faisant ça je peux gagner
encore de la profondeur et un étage que
je pouvais pas attendre mais il ya
toujours pas de mécanisme à l'intérieur
si j'appuie la crise pose plus c'est
bien dommage ici ici ici je les milla
pour pas le père mais en vrai et si je
les remettais pas dans le même sens
c'était comment c'était petit grand
petit vent au départ dont petit je peux
faire petit grand grand petit petit
grand grand petit à ce que son permis
par autre chose
ah la vache vous entendez 2 clics
d'ailleurs c'est complètement
élémentaire j'ai là c'est pas moi qui ai
plus le mouvement si je la tourne un peu
comme ça elle va finir tout seul elle
est complètement et monté par l'autre
côté donc si je fais ça est-ce que je
peux bouger un peu les côtés le dessus
dessous oh oui je peux bouger le côté le
côté peu le descendre je peux bien
descendent même je peux tirer ça ici ça
me fait une ouverture là et du coup lui
je peux pousser là comme ça ça me fait
une ouverture là et après par contre je
peux pas tirer lui donc admettons si je
suis comme ça et que je referme et je
reprenne mon ancienne configuration ou
alors gérer c'est mon truc du bouton
aussi c'était pas mal ça
je commence par quoi puis je peux aussi
le mettre là comme ça qu'est né lui en
boutons ici comme tout à l'heure
parce que comme on a fait les deux
mouvements peut-être qu'on peut faire
autre chose maintenant
après difficile et difficile
et au départ j'étais à petit grand petit
si je remets le petit lac grands là
c'est un peu différentes positions clés
pour voir si ça si maintenant qu'on a
passé une étape on a accès à autre chose
à l'intérieur
[Musique]
à
ça se passe pas si bien non plus non non
écouter bouger deux éléments là pour
l'instant
voilà
tu vas jamais complété phrase tu connais
magazine curieuse pas du tout tu n'as
pas le magazine curieuse pas du tout
qu'est-ce que ça tu peux me rapportera
porte mois 20 exemplaires s'il te plaît
pourquoi je vous parle de curieuse parce
que dans le magazine à paraître le mois
prochain au mois de mai tout un dossier
sur les casse tête voilà ça c'est bien à
la une car la merci des marizys curieuse
c'est ça c'est la troisième année que ça
existe c'est mon magazine qu'on a créé
le premier numéro est paru quand il est
paru en mars 2020 le premier numéro est
mais moi je ne vous parle même pas de
celui de mars ou d'avril mais celui à
paraître en mai sa magazine qui fait à
peu près 50 pages un peu plus ce qui
arrive directement dans vos boîtes aux
lettres où que vous habitiez dans le
monde c'est compris dans le prix l'envoi
postal donc partout dans le monde il ya
10 numéros par an parce qu'il ya un
numéro après qu'en juillet août et un
autre de décembre janvier et c'est
uniquement par abonnement pourquoi parce
que pour vous c'est moins cher en
faisant ça on imprime que la bonne
quantité ça permet quoi d'imprimer que
la bonne quantité loïc
ne pas faire de déchets parce que les
magazines que tu as dans les kiosques
comme il y en a partout dans tous les
kiosques j'imagine bien qu'ils ont pas
tous vendus et après c'est plusieurs
dizaines voire centaines de milliers
d'exemplaires qui tous les jours toutes
les semaines sont détruits bah c'est pas
très cool co logiquement parlant donc
nous on fait comme ça c'est pour ça que
c'est pas en classe je vous mets un lien
dans la description si vous vous abonnez
avant le 15 de ce mois ci eh bien vous
recevrez vos numéros à partir de celui
de mai c'est comme ça ça se passe il ya
un petit mois de décalage comme ça
abonnez vous nous on a tendance à fait
trente et une minutes qu'on est dessus
j'ai l'impression qu'on n'avance pas
tant que ça ça ça me fatigue un peu
aussi à ce trou il ya tout un jeu de
ouf on l'enfoncé alors que la polarité
pas la bonne
parce que là il se passe quelque chose
de si l'un j'avais entendu ça fait toute
une culture s'est passé un truc
tu as un fabu assez classe je le mets
dans le sens où les aimants rups euro
poussent l'un l'autre jeudi c'est
peut-être ça le le bouton secret caché
le presser
yves petitjean petit petit rien grands
groupes comme ça qu'on veut voir
[Musique]
voilà comment en 37 minutes je suis
exactement revenu à mon état d'origine
pour infléchir la politique passée s'est
passé beaucoup de choses n'ont pas
changé dans le bon sens c'est d'ailleurs
dans l'autre polarité
j'arrive à déplacer sur le côté
[Musique]
et là
on a vu au coude avant juste avant
j'arrivais à pousser des choses
[Musique]
si je le fais comme ça c'est attendent
alors je pouvais pas le monde est là je
peux le dessin je peux pas pousser mais
si je le mets en polarisation inversée
à [ __ ] il faut descendre un petit peu
et monte et on peut hélas à l'intérieur
d'un seul c'est pas la même là on voit
qu'il ya un trou de dans une encoche et
donc j'imagine que je peux pousser lui
dans l'encoche ah non dommage ça aurait
été sympa ok ça je peux pas avec mais
par contre je peux faire ça et oui du
coup en dessous je peux le débloquer sa
et du coup est-ce que je peux descendre
lui non annoncés dans le bois de feu
résolu se serait terminée veulent ok
mais ça reste intéressant c'est dommage
qu'on puisse pas le déplacer parce que
quand même il est pas si mal
dommage si je le mets à l'inversé
celui-là
ça ressemble à ce que j'ai fait à
l'heure ce que lui est monté ça c'est la
première fois que ça nous arrive qu'ils
sont montés laico dispute donc c'est
forcément qui bloque et peut-être qu'il
ya une distance ah ouais super ok il y
avait une distance à trouver pour lui
permettre à lui de s'enfoncer dans lui
en fait directement donc en bas autres
aussi et donc au dessus comme en dessous
je peux je peux faire ce décalage l'a
donc lui commence maintenant à gigoter
un petit peu donc je dois être au bout
parce que si j'arrive à faire bouger lui
maintenant ça veut dire que je pourrais
ouvrir en bas et en haut ou peut-être
que l'un des deux d'ailleurs parce que
là c'est vachement plus creux ici que là
donc là il faut retrouver une autre
configs donc admettons si on fait ce
coup ci le grand la
même temps vous séparez vous et moi ça
fait 54 milliers non sakho peut-être
milliers de quoi c'est pas vu
ça commence à faire mais je pense que je
suis au bout je suis pas loin de
l'africain en provoquer tu peux le faire
dit pas tout vous comme certains sites
bonne en ce sens là c'était dans le sens
où j'arrive au bout en fait
j'ai réussi à bouger trois parties sur
les cartes je pense que si j'arrivais à
bouger elle pense que je termine il ya
des histoires de polarité mon pote aux
meilleurs jeunes vieux truc de frustrant
c'est je sens quand ça accroche quand ça
se repoussent comme ça fait des choses à
sa vie à sa vie tu veux leur parler tout
le temps que je fasse un petit pipi
qui pouvaient j'ai pu qu les aimait
waouh vous allez voir combien de temps
dure mais pipi grâce à à loïc
[Musique]
te raconte la petite gifle j'ai sauvé 54
au chat de la noyade ah oui c'est pas
comme la petite gifle mais il ya autant
de respect et oui c'est moi qu'elles
sont
une minute trente le temps d'un pipe le
pic ou bleu boon et au pardon excusez
moi
vomito fob la phobie du vomi et métaux
fob y les métaux phobie on teste les
confits nom précis cette config la si je
récupère lui et que je le maintiens avec
se doit la ex tente là
l'appuyant
donc ça ne fait rien et en appui en
admettant on peut la réalité inversé
comme taddart non plus
subi je leur fais le petit vers le camp
là donc je ramène bull en mode clé c'est
bon il reste
enfoncée que je fais ça
là on a le même truc très satisfaisants
même tout alors ouais
enfin si ça pousse plus que tu as l'air
je pouffe
dommage parce que ça ressemble bien
quand même
l'élu le plus en france et plus encore
d'ici là ça pousse là clairement
à fallait le retirer après
donc là ça se lève à fond ici ok en fait
parce que je les retire est là et là
incroyable
c'est incroyable et c'est très joli je
ne sais pas du tout à quoi ça correspond
vieilles pièces décroisée vous savez des
gars de croisade de trésor des templiers
on dirait vraiment vraiment ça
félicitations à monsieur erik feller
parce que c'est vraiment fou j'aimerais
faire une dinguerie j'aimerais le
démonter pour voir comment il fait à
l'intérieur parce que ce qui rend ouf
c'est qu'on voit rien du tout pas vite
ce côté là ni de ce côté là on ne sera
jamais vraiment comment c'est fait à
l'intérieur c'est une folie c'est
magnifique bravo bravo à eric foner
merci beaucoup à l'insoluble casse tête
de m'avoir traquer ce casse tête et il
me l'avoir fait parvenir du coup c'est
très gentil à le je vais leur envoyer
évidemment vous avez le lien vers
l'insoluble dans la description passé
voir cette boutique 100 % française elle
fait plaisir dans la description
toujours vous avez le prochain numéro de
curieuses si vous voulez vous abonner
baveux n'ai
je pas d'arguments mais passez voir au
moins le site de curieuses lire des
articles qui sont gratuits et tout comme
ça vous connaîtrez un peu ce projet de
magazine puis prenez soin de vous parce
que ça ça c'est important n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner à cette chaîne youtube
d'activer la cloche pour voir passer des
vidéos youtube en ce moment avec le
tictoc c'est dur on va pas se mentir je
suis aussi sur tik tok suit partout
toute manière allez prenez soin de vous
et à très bientôt ciao